I know people this is the Reuben report
I'm the guy who invented the new sift
lightsaber in the force awakens trailer
dave rubin and I've got nerd alert skim
horror and buzzfeed's Louis pipes made
with me yes I did invent that lightsaber
I know you want people to believe you
did but I actually did it we've got a
lot to get to so let's get right to it
you know I'm starting to think call me
crazy I'm starting to think that the
Republicans don't like President Obama
and that President Obama doesn't like
the Republicans I have a feeling on this
one John Boehner he he was given a
little speech about immigration to some
Republicans the other day and he had
this to say about the president the
president the other hand has ignored the
will of the American people and he's
refused to listen he himself or his
decision to take unilateral and on
immigration action he himself said
exceeded his authority and makes it
harder for the American people and our
elected representatives to trust his
word on any issue okay so I don't want
to make this about the immigration thing
we've talked a lot about that and we'll
do plenty more segments about that but I
want to talk about the trust issue
because of what I was thinking when I
saw that was well I don't trust you and
I don't trust the president really don't
trust any of them and that's how I
wanted to start this thing do you guys
trust any of these people do you trust
Boehner any less or more than you trust
Obama or vice versa or any which way you
can say that it's just rhetoric really i
mean its just oh you don't trust him
he's not trustworthy and if you say that
it's sort of deflection and branding
it's it's sort of ridiculous how
marketed this is yeah do you trust these
people do trust politicians no but the
only people I trust less than
politicians are the American people so
when it comes to like you know Obama
doing something that kind of bypasses
may be the dumbest voters I'm fine with
that too yes I don't really trust anyone
yeah I was a lot of x-files growing up
so I learned my lesson so most of your
political beliefs are based in the
x-files oh absolutely what that
something's out there he's out there
trust no one yeah something about little
green men so I when I was watching this
clip and there's a lot more where he
goes into the immigration stuff in
executive action and yes many times
Obama said that he doesn't have the
power to
do it and now of course he's going ahead
and doing it what does that say just
about our system that everyone lies like
we got an election coming and you know
2015 is gonna be a big year for the 2016
election my suspicion is that we're just
gonna hear lies for a year it's gonna be
the year of the lie you act like you've
never heard of this before it seems
worse to me now is it maybe cuz I'm more
of an adult or something I don't know it
just seems like that we've gotten to a
point and I think this is partly an
obama thing where i wanted to believe in
him so much and now i've just seen that
everyone including this guy they just
lie so we're just gonna hear a lot of it
next year maybe that is that
disillusionment i mean i think people
had a lot of probably were too much
faith in obama as he's proven but that
doesn't mean he's the one bad guy it's
theirs it just it's a pool of that oh
yeah I have no lo guys yeah I have no
love for John Boehner it's politics just
a big soap opera that's what I really
think like what they don't really talk
about stuff really they don't really go
into the room and work out the stuff
anymore right they just sort of thing
and it's it's actually a lot easier for
me to understand as a TV viewer so I
appreciate okay so let's let's put it in
your spot no I'm great this is great
like we can just keep talking about lies
and deception and not actually the
issues and I'm totally fine with that
but isn't that what they want in a weird
way like in the old days they used to
talk about how Bill Clinton used to like
actually go into a room with Newt
Gingrich and really like work out policy
and I feel like these days that's just
not something that they can you picture
Obama and Vayner in room really like I
feel like they don't even do they act
like children around each other ya know
he's I don't want to talk work with him
yeah me no like and it's it's sort of
yeah you're Eddie you're right it has
gotten maybe more more of like a rivalry
more more partisan than it should be
yeah um we're in like season like what
season are we in love this I love you
guys like we've jumped the shark like so
many times I guess I just don't worry
about anymore yeah if you give me a show
that we can really relate this to that
really jumped the shark or I guess we
could use happy days after the shark
jumping right literally the show fella
that's where we learned the phones is so
president I mean he's like 80 years old
I would vote for Henry Winkler well
major Beauty Winkler sure but the fun's
is you know in real time as probably
should be dead by now yeah so final
thought on this whenever
time I see these types of things it
makes me think that maybe we need a
little bit of what they have in Europe
which is the where they have a president
that's just like the the figurehead and
the Prime Minister that's actually doing
this stuff and I feel like maybe we need
a little of that because we want obama
to be like our rock star and the guy
that plays basketball and he was cool
with weed and blah blah blah but then we
also want him to be the president do you
think maybe we need I thought we had
that I thought like Oprah was our
figurehead and then everyone else is
just kind of doing other stuff behind
the scenes that's that's fair do you
think what do you think I think it's
possible for him to do both yeah it's
isn't it too much it hard but is it cool
yeah but I don't know I think he spends
too much time trying to be cool and not
enough time trying again it's branding
it's all brand yeah it's all so
you don't think we should split the
presidency into a prime ministership
this is the second time I've been on
that show this showing you back I really
want to get that out of you can I really
really wanted to do anyway I don't trust
any of them horn produced in the UK is
going to be censored that's right
according to a 2003 amendment to the
Communications Act porn that is actually
made in the UK is going to be censored a
lot of different acts that you probably
like you pervert and we've got a list of
them right here spanking caning what's
Kayne and Kim I don't know all right
we'll get to that in a minute louis dee
a caning would you like the caning it's
not hitting with a cane hitting with a
cane that's right okay an aggressive
whipping aggressive whipping is with the
whip if you would come with a cane to be
caning yeah I think your painting is
where the cane whipping is with a whip
there you go what if I hate you the
stick that's sticking that's aggressive
stick I get it I get it okay penetration
by any object quote associated with
violence will get more to that one I
think that's kinda interesting physical
or verbal abuse regardless of if it's
consensual euro lenia which is more
commonly known as water sports female
ejaculation strangulation facesitting I
want to talk about that one too and
fisting okay so just to be very clear
they're banning this to be produced in
the UK so if you live in the UK fear not
you can still get it from Germany in the
US and Japan and wherever else you
getting your porn from but I do think
this is kind of interesting because in
we live in a world where there are no
borders anymore
right everyone gets everything online
anyway so what is the UK government
actually trying to accomplish here
except they're just going to hurt their
own economy they're their own porn I
feel like I want to hear someone say
squirting with a British accent so
that's really cutting into that for me
Kim can you do squirting with the wow
you can't do that no no no now can you
squirt right now I mean can you say
squirting with the British accent
wedding oh that yeah all right so we're
fine so we're good yeah I worried for a
minute there but I think we're okay okay
but really doesn't it seem odd that they
would outlaw the act being done in their
country but they're not gonna stop
people from watching this stuff so what
are they really trying to accomplish see
I thought maybe violence but a lot of
this is really arbitrary I mean
facesitting is is that violent well
they're arguing that you could actually
do some serious damage that way and I'm
sure someone has died from facesitting
you could crush someone even if someone
has died from fisting perhaps yeah
really aggressive just vaginal punching
I don't know but also things like I mean
the verbal stuff right way to be like
you know I guess you could die of
humiliation yeah that's strange it says
regardless if of if it's consensual
right right so these are you protecting
with this yeah I don't understand what's
going on here right so the final three
those last we can we throw the list up
for just a second want to be very clear
on this so we know we're talking about
the last three strangulation so that's
obviously choking someone facesitting as
louis points out and fisting all fall
under the BBC FC view of potentially
life-endangering so i think that there's
something i er I have a problem with the
female ejaculation part that seems
especially wrong to me that seems you're
not into that it's not like you can I
mean some people can control that sure
yeah but if it happens it happens yeah I
don't want some porn star who happens to
be a little bit more squirty to be to be
banned from doing porn in the UK right
so it's our fault so this is squirt
discrimination if it is a guy squirt all
the time and there's a problem I don't
see that on this list it feels very
sexist to me yeah why really though when
you think about the amount of porn
that's out
everyone knows that I'm you can get any
kind of porn that you want and all that
what do you think the UK's really trying
to do like what are they really saying
to their people here what is it that
they're getting at here are they trying
to be prude are they trying to be as
they are they having their like
Christian conservative moment that
stereotype of typical British gentleman
going like Oh tut tut you know ah so
this is has to do with their tea and
they're happy these are unseemly things
yeah these are things that like I mean I
also have a problem with the the obvious
OCA with violence because if you don't
want to like use a gun on someone in a
sexual way that's fine but you could
hurt someone with a dildo you know what
I mean I just spirals it's dangerous to
kind of start censoring these things
because suddenly everything's a weapon
that's right people you can hurt someone
with a dildo let's go netflix CEO Reed
Hastings had some interesting things to
say about the future of cable television
and believe it or not yeah he thinks
that things dying pretty quickly we've
got the quote right here so what
Hastings is referring to here is that
Nielsen is going to start measuring
Netflix traffic next month so he goes on
to say it's not very relevant there's so
much viewing that happens on a mobile
phone or an iPad that Nielsen won't
capture it's kind of like the horse you
know the horse was good until we had the
car the age of broadcast TV will
probably last until 2030 okay I mean
this seems pretty obvious we've talked a
bunch about this that people are cutting
the cord left and right so my first
question to you guys is have you guys
cut yeah cord yet you you're a cord
cutter done you have no cable none
you're doing this all online doing great
and you're doing great yes your bill is
down I don't spend a hundred dollars a
month on cable yeah now Louis I know
you're a big TV watcher and you're in
the biz right more than that on cable
I'm not cutting the cord it's different
though I mean I do have to watch
everything I have to be up on everything
I write about television so I don't have
the option yet of cutting the cord at
the same time I think 20 30 is like I
think we're actually gonna see the end
of broadcast well before that ah I think
it's coming faster than 20 30 yeah so to
your point I wanted to bring this up so
TV viewership dropped a full fifty
percent between 2002 and 2012 and that's
well before Netflix really a lot of that
the first half of that at least is
really before Netflix really sort of
picked up steam
so yeah I'm with you I think that this
thing is going to happen way before then
I think it could happen maybe in five
years or something do you miss anything
do you feel like you've lost anything by
not having access to the cable channel
how much time I've spent just like
skipping through channels looking for
something to watch and it's just and
then I'll find something I'll be like oh
no it's fine it's not like something I
love ya and I think I have a lot more
personal time now and it's great yeah
what about net neutrality because that
to me is one of the biggest issues that
we have going on today you know it's
funny obama appointed a guy who was a
telecom lobbyists to figure out the
rules on net neutrality and then you
know boat is it two weeks ago Obama said
that he's for open and free internet yet
he appointed a guy to be in charge of it
that's not so another one of those
things as per our previous segment but
how does this make net neutrality that
much more important that if everyone's
cutting the cord it's always been
important and we've always worried that
you know once these telecom agencies who
also happen to be cable companies are
able to throttle Netflix even more yeah
they're going to do it so this this is
important I mean this is an outdated
model and we can even see that
exemplified by Nielsen ratings failing
to include online numbers and it's it
needs to it needs to change or it needs
to die one of those things is happening
yeah so for someone like you who watches
all this stuff that your business is in
this and there's and forgetting people
that's business in it there's plenty of
people that watch a ton of TV that don't
want to cut the court when this thing
changes you think the ala carte way of
getting all your channel so you'll just
stop watching certain I mean I hope yeah
I think that it's already happened I
mean if you look at now we can watch
stuff on TV on netflix on hulu on itunes
and yahoo i mean there's there's
actually at this point too much and I
feel like it's become there's too much
TV to watch I would say yeah and I think
we're gonna get to a point where people
start people stop watching things just
because there's so many options start
focusing more on a network they really
like or on a show they really like it
less on everything right final thought
of this what are you guys watching these
days I actually watch a lot of Netflix
you watch allowed yeah it's like give me
like two shows that you're watching
right now I watched all of orange is the
new black like in one weekend both
seasons yep
so yeah and I'm catching up on old shows
that i didn't really but I either loved
or I wanted to watch to begin with
you're just watching battlestar loop i
know it's off netflix native it's been
off since like november i'll do a little
research into that what are you watching
i wouldn't recommend to work i just
discovered the cosby show guys i just
wanted to be a little controversial no I
i watch everything I watched too much
like I said I'd watch everything and
then I wonder why don't with social life
um you had to say Cosby great yeah I had
to say cup I want to open the door well
that does bring me to one other thing
that I think is kind of shooting cuz one
thing about their I do think there's
something to be said for actual
programming on these channels like
something there is something to be said
for flicking without an appointment you
know you mean when you're just flicking
on like a Sunday afternoon and flicking
yeah you're going dirty can ye going
dirty squirting so we're headed in that
yeah no but when you really like a
Sunday afternoon and you just flip
flipping through the channels right at
not flicking your flipping through the
channels and you just catch something as
opposed to having to go search for it I
think we might lose a little something
when them you definitely do it i think
that there's a reason why i prefer
Golden Girls marathon to getting my DVDs
out there's an elk I just love it I let
this take take over but we'll get used
to it you know if I if I had a choice to
pick that pose I wanted a watch of a
like an eight hour long marathon I
probably would yeah once I got used to
that idea once you got used to it all
right well we shall see but the internet
is here is to stay and hopefully net
neutrality doesn't the whole thing
up in case my feelings on that aren't
clear enough all right let's let's talk
about the south because down south the
American Atheists group has put up some
controversial billboards right in time
for the holiday season I think we've got
one of the billboards right here yeah as
you can see it's a little girl penning a
letter to Santa dear Santa all i want
for christmas is to skip church I'm too
old for fairy tales ok so this billboard
is now right now it's in Memphis and
Nashville obviously in Tennessee st.
Louis and Fort Smith Arkansas so they're
going sort of right to the religious
people now things like this have been
done before you guys may remember they
something like this last year atheists
did something like this last year in
Times Square certainly not as religious
let's say as the deep south so I think
this brings up a lot of interesting
stuff oh but we've got a quote from the
group's president before we do that even
children know church's spew absurdity
which is why they don't want to attend
services enjoy the time with your family
and friends instead today's adults have
no obligation to pretend to believe the
lies their parents believe that's David
Silverman American Atheists president
okay I've been doing a lot about atheism
on the show and I'm for atheists I think
they get unfairly attacked in this
country relentlessly especially lately
but is this a good move by them like are
they doing a little too much here too
like is this just going to wrangle up
the religious well I think it's
important that Athens atheists get
recognized and legitimized more and it's
probably good to have a billboard
campaign but i do feel this one is
trying to poke a fight right it's just
going to devolve into just aggression
and not really understanding which is
what we need right which is sort of what
we're seeing already because now they're
getting a big backlash online on this I
mean I guess timing is everything and
they're purposely doing this right
before the holidays that's also the time
when religious people obviously are
feeling a little more religious little
bit more defensive for a little more
defensive yeah so I may I hate this
particular ad campaign that girls not
too old for fairy tales and she is well
Conda and she should totally believe in
Santa because Santa's great that's it
that's an interesting point we can we
throw the image up again let's look at
the image one more time that is a good
point because there is a certain age
right that that we all believe that
children are allowed to believe in the
tooth fairy or whatever it is so that
girl's probably what do we think she is
maybe 50 mi old kids are let's say eight
sure yeah it's borderline right I guess
eat I don't think kids want to skip
church because they're too old for fairy
tales I want they I think they want to
skip church because it's boring and
their kids well that I guess goes to the
quote of David Silverman who was saying
yeah there
kids i I just I guess I just feel like
aren't like atheists being atheist is
the easiest thing you have to does not
believe so whenever you can spread the
word of a tease it always seems a little
bit like counterintuitive to me yeah
atheists are gonna be pissed at you
though because there is a it's a brave
choice to not buy into I'm not saying
that a brave choice i'm saying that i
don't know what the Billboard actually
accomplishes except for crushing the
dreams of a child I don't mean a dreams
of like Jesus Christ I mean the dreams
of like Santa and uh no she's writing to
Santa well if she's but like someone's
was for your ears Santa's not real do uh
do the non-religious people in this
country need to cook sort of band
together you know we went every time we
do an atheist story I always say you
know it's like we've got every group has
you know they say well this many black
people vote for this and miss many white
people vote for this and this many
Latinos work for this if there's a whole
bunch of non-religious / atheist people
if they had a voting bloc wouldn't we do
a lot of good in this country probably
but you know one of the things about
religion is that it's a way to organize
people and galvanize people into one
specific movement and it's a little bit
harder this way and I feel a theism is
really misunderstood by many people yeah
jus agree that would be she wouldn't
lose her mind if any of her
grandchildren said I'm an atheist right
so there's no unifying force I guess I
like kind of the point that's I guess
that is the portion we get behind like
an atheist leader guy got like a theater
clearly we can't you know get behind
right but that I guess is the part of
this that while I agree with the
sentiment of what they're trying to do
that's the part of it that I think might
be a little off-putting like in a weird
way they're sort of becoming by doing
some like a direct attack on this
they're just playing the same game that
they claim that the religious people are
playing right bye-bye sort of mocking
someone's beliefs so I don't know that
it's sort of there's some sort of loop
Darth Vader thing here oh no to me be
careful about what you become kind of
thing are you with me something say it
reminds me of college when there were
these like it started in high school
these straight edge kids who were like
no drinking the smoking no sex before
marriage very like clean cut and I was
like what happen to them well they all
they all failed sex and drugs no but I
mean like it was one of those things
where I was like you know everyone knows
their options like you don't have to
assert yourself as not doing these
things you can just kind of exists in
that way and people who want to find it
will find in people who want to turn
away from religion will turn away from
religion especially as they get older
and more educated and step away from it
when you proselytize in any way I feel
like it turns people off because it's
exactly what you don't want to be doing
it it's exactly what the opposite side
is doing all right I love this story
Willie Murphy is a 77 year old
grandmother and you may have seen this
viral video of her she is a weightlifter
a power trainer and she's just got a
great spirit and she's got some pretty
kick ass muscles let's take a look so I
started the weight training so little by
little I got stronger and stronger so
does the gun would go off boom I just
those ladies that was four years ago and
since then I have been a competitive
power lifter the audience would say oh
that old lady and she lifted and they
say oh and uh and guess what my car got
stuck I'm pushing my car which is a
fabulous thing powerlifting my
grandchildren I can lift them up without
any problem and the best of all I don't
need any help when I'm carrying my
groceries you see that's what it's about
it's about life l.i.f.e life I mean if
you don't love that woman I really don't
know what say to you everything about
her not only the physical stuff but her
empowerment her self empowerment the
sense of humor even the way she speaks
and yes all about l.i.f.e life life life
just I just love it when you see videos
like that do you think I could be that
person or do you think oh i'm
already it's too late for me listen I
haven't been to the gym in three months
so but I love her do you ever maybe I
should go to the gym now maybe you need
her as a trainee I do that she'd
probably be held with the trainer I
would listen though you she seems wife
and it's nice to get advice from a
grandmother don't you think sure I mean
I definitely think that grandma can kick
my ass um I don't know to what end but I
see these stories I'm like I'm always
wondering what does she know that we
don't know like why is she so buff at
that age what's coming I think she knows
that well time to
if your own stuff and pull your car and
push your car when I met old I plan on
being very laid-back like even more so
than I am now yeah because you're very
high-strung right now yeah but I mean
like I'm out say I'm not saying very
active and I want to be even less active
as I get further along in life yeah
would you guys rather live a life of
carelessness and freedom and whatever
you want to call it and drop dead at 80
or a more conservative life and get
those last 20 years and go to the even
hundreds balancing between the two to be
honest so you want 90 you are a little
bit of life a little bit yeah yeah don't
go crazy yeah just just lift a 45-pound
weight yeah she's doing she's doing a
lot more than what do you think we just
assume the medical science will get us
to a point where we cannot exercise and
live to be 120 anyway that's the dream
right that is that I don't want to be a
76 year old weightlifter right you just
want to take a pill yeah that'll get you
there um what I was thinking when I was
watching this though is that we're so
quick to dismiss and mock old people in
society all the time right we see this
all the time people someone old on tell
that mean people get fazed at a
television all the time where we should
be learning from old people they've been
around the block more than us right why
are we so quick to dismiss old people I
don't think I'm the right person to ask
because I you know I feel sad for when
people are mean to old people and the
elderly and disrespectful and I don't
think we should be that way yeah why do
you think we are though because we're
I don't know just find him at
delete you with her why do they also
tend to have a lot more old-fashioned
views not all the time but a lot of the
time so it can be it can be frustrating
to argue or debate with an old person
about many issues that kind of we see is
common sense that they see as being
completely backwards right although I
think a lot of thats even changing we
did it we did a thing last week about
those three grandmas that took bong hits
I don't know if you guys saw the viral
video on that which was pretty great
there's plenty of videos out there about
older people that are now completely
okay with gay marriage on that so that I
guess that's the beauty of the internet
maybe it's speeding things up a little
bit birds my grandparents are okay with
gay marriage and they're okay with a lot
of things that I thought they wouldn't
be because they're over 90 yeah but are
they dead lifting like Natalie no
there's a fit though they should I yours
they're all dead but I I mean I'm not
say we shouldn't give them a chance
certainly give everyone a chance to kind
of evolved with their views yeah I think
a lot of the the kind of just comfort
that we get with another generation is
that we feel like they're kind of
removed from what we understand as like
being our society now of versus what
they kind of appreciate it to be theirs
there you go all right let's talk about
poo you know we did the story last week
about the the bus in the UK that is
being powered by who let's turn sorry i
miss it out that's right all right let's
talk about poo you know we did the story
last week about the bus in the UK that's
being powered by I mean I'm not say we
shouldn't give them a chance certainly
give everyone a chance to kind of
evolved with their views yeah I think a
lot of the the kind of just comfort that
we get with another generation is that
we feel like they're kind of removed
from what we understand as like being
our society now of versus what they kind
of appreciate be theirs all right let's
talk about poo you know we did the story
last week about the bus in the UK that's
being powered by human poo and then we
came up with another poo story this week
this is wild there is a new product
called poop re and this is they're
pushing this towards women who don't
want their poo to smell but don't take
my word for it we've got a bit of the ad
right here simply splits poo pourri in
the bowl to create a film on the water's
surface that actually traps the odors in
their porcelain prison and when your
little astronaut splash down and make
contact with the film they release
pooper ease pleasant aromas so all those
around you can smell as a refreshing
bouquet of essential oils yes it is a
real product and yes it really works
yeah so if you are in a hundred percent
clear it's not just the air freshener
that you're going to be spraying around
once you poo you're actually locking the
poo smell down in the toilet and their
marketing this towards women so Kim I
have to go to you first would you like
poo pourri is it marketed to women men
have smelly poo but I think women fear
the poo smell more than my life or at
least that's I think what they think I
was little to carry the spray around for
the rest of my life because I'm so
embarrassed of poop well girls have
pocketbooks
guys don't I'm not carrying around pool
spray in my purse for the rest of my
life I'll tell you that I am I have no
problem with that if it works I'll carry
it around why are we so afraid of human
things when we did the story on the poop
bus last week I mean it's a great idea
right we're taking our waste and turning
it into something so that we can get off
oil blah blah and there were a lot of
people in the conversation alice is
gross its disgusting it's a biohazard
isn't it to sort poop everywhere ok so a
lot of bacteria in their day so the poop
bus is slightly different than locking
down the poop smell so sorry forget the
bus then but for this particularly why
are we so afraid of our bodily
everything we do is to hide our bodily
functions and you know what's the deal
well no one likes bad smells no it's
just about I mean it you definitely
could look at why we're afraid of our
own bodies and why we're afraid of our
waste but on a practical level I feel
like a product like this it's not about
shame is about just kind of carrying
yourself in a nicer nicer smelling way
right I guess we've all been to like a
fancy party where you have to go
sometimes you gotta go and you know then
you go ask somebody's coming in the
bathroom right after me and you have if
you had your little poop smell you're a
little poop spray wouldn't you want the
poop spray at that point because
otherwise you have to say when the guy
walks out or you walk out the guy what
yeah I was before me you know I don't
defecate but if I did that I would
really enjoy a product like this I also
do you feel like there is this comfort I
mean there was a story recently about
fecal transplants and how there's yeah
you know advances in medicine that way
but there's a lot of discomfort with the
idea of taking a pill of poop in it yeah
but if we just kind of got past that we
could do a lot of good so just to be one
hundred percent clear on what what lewis
is talking about there we have Cara
Santa Maria on next week who cleans up a
lot of my science mess but basically
they're literally transplanting other
people's poo into other people to sort
of get the bacteria the good bacteria
from the original person interview I
think you did a segment on this son nerd
earlier didn't ya soso poo has some
merit yes but it you know it's not just
any poo it has to be
it has to from a donor the biome of that
person's body and there's a lot of
checking this is not to be done without
doctor supervision yeah just so you know
but but to your point people sort of
fear the idea of this like it just
sounds so gross and that's what there
are plenty of doctors who have said well
the reason we can't really get this
thing going is because just talking
about poop makes people on cut if it
smelled better oh so you wanna maybe
we'd have an easier time with it oh
that's not a bad idea so the poo pourri
people need to get in on it with the
Pooh transplant people this is a shitty
topic nothing and the Pooh marketing
people all right final thought of this
um do you think maybe we're missing
something here I mean think about I walk
my dog every day dogs are sniffing each
others butts they're pooping all over
the place cats pee all over so that they
can get back home if they go anywhere so
are we losing something that's very
natural humans you know what I mean we
put ourselves in big houses and we're
just separating ourselves from Earth
humans are disgusting we are leaking out
fluids sebum this we are just bags of
disgusting liquids and I think we don't
like to think about it because we like
to transcend maybe that level of being
gross and also being mortal I don't know
maybe it's very poetic yeah but we're
gross we're all gross inside together we
are gross horribly disgusting things and
on that note let's move on all right so
this is pretty cool Tommy Hilfiger is
coming out with solar powered jackets
yeah that's right we've got a picture of
the solar powered jackets and why would
you wear a solar power jacket first up I
actually think that looks decently cool
um you guys on board that part with me
so far before I say why you would wear
it the girl looks like a TARDIS it what
about the guy Louis give me some guy
fashion there that is the ugliest thing
I've seen in a long time yeah I think
that they're disgusting if you made that
a little if it was black if it was just
black and you had some of those solar
power things it would be kind of
futuristic put a different jacket on it
would be great yeah all right you just
don't like that style jacket plaid no
it's horrible all right let's not get
hung up on the fashion too much I'll
tell you a little bit more about what
they're doing so they have jackets
obviously for both men and women and
they generate energy on the go so that
you can power your iPhone
other devices they feature flexible
solar panels on the back that can
generate enough power to recharge a
standard smartphone up to four times
they also have two USB ports Kim you're
gonna have to give me some ideas on what
we can do with that and fifty percent of
the proceeds of the jacket are donated
to the Fresh Air Fund who helped new
york city kids experience being in the
outdoors how much would you pay for that
jacket five hundred ninety nine dollars
retail you know if they black friday
this thing we're looking around for 50 i
think but we already passed black friday
so i guess not i think this is pretty
cool look we're all carrying around the
phones right starbucks is now going to
do this thing with wireless charging at
all their tables that's supposed to be
coming next year we're all running out
of power constantly think about our
batteries have drained while we've been
sitting here so this is pretty cool this
would be super useful at a convention
like comic-con or something where it's
super sunny and my phone is dying all
the time and I need it for Instagram I
need it wait i'm not sure if you're
being sarcastic is it sunny in Comic Con
isn't it in a giant of it is out a night
oh because it's all it's taking over San
Diego so I would be able to you know
I'll go do this obstacle course and also
charge my house with you but wearable
tech is you know i like it i'm a fan but
yeah that's a very expensive that's the
price point alright so let's let's not
get hung up on the price one so you're
forgetting the price point and
forgetting the fashion ability of it is
that a word fashionability sure are you
down with this idea it's pretty alonia
in theory it's great but i feel like you
can't forget the price and the fashion
of it because I you know wearable tech
is definitely the future but we have to
kind of make strides in terms of what we
want to actually wear what we can afford
to wear so it's not going to be
something that everyone can can pick up
and put on without feeling silly it's
not going to really matter right so
isn't that just part of just how
business goes like even this for black
friday i kept seeing these literally
like 40 or 50 inch tvs that were 200
bucks or 250 bucks i bought my first
plasma whatever it was like six years
ago it was twenty four hundred dollars
so don't we sort of need isn't that just
how business works that we need some of
these expensive things to start it and
then eventually cheap guys always going
to be more expensive and bulkier at
first that's why I'm usually not an
early adopter so yeah wait a few years
and maybe it'll be a hundred bucks so if
you power your phone with this thing
what are you doing with those two other
USB ports charging your iPad so you got
your iPad your phone you could almost
think I want to walk around with every
devices yes my jacket back started to
see by the way this was making me think
you know we did so many stories probably
about a year ago about google glass and
everyone was gonna be wearing it I've
literally here in LA which is a pretty
early adopter place right I've literally
only seen one guy wearing Google glass
and he's this guy in West Hollywood who
wears google glass all time and he also
rides a one of that scooter thing that
Segway any rides a sec because it looks
ridiculous because though so that's it I
mean they it could have been I mean if
google glass looked like something
people would actually wear I feel like
it got a lot farther yeah it were more
affordable yeah do you think there's
some hesitancy to go this route of
wearing all this stuff like we're so
inundated with technology all the time
that I do think part of us it's like I
mean wearable tech has its cool I think
it's useful but it hasn't really caught
on as much as it should have or
projected to have by now I a lot of it
is maybe it's fashion related I mean
things take a while to catch on you feel
weird being feeling like I'm the only
one who looks like this yes it's it's
gonna take a while to cotton on I think
I Louis if they took that lovely sweater
you're wearing right now and put some
solar panels on it sure yeah I'm not
against that you're not against that
here's the problem why would I be
wearing the sweater if it were really
sunny outside you could still get some
rain that's a good point these things
are jackets and now you guys oom you get
less so I don't know this for a fact but
I would imagine if you're we're
somewhere that you need a jacket that
the sun is probably less strong for the
solar panels can you I'm not something
you get something you get a little juice
and you don't need a ton of power to
power the eye okay that's my completely
unscientific I just know like what about
like a like a like a hat with solar
panels on it oh that's more like didn't
I think I feel like Michael J Fox were
that maybe in back to the future too he
might have possibly i'm sort of me
empower the hoverboard yeah and that
exactly that's how hoverboards will be
powered in the future okay we got one
more for ya this is sort of interesting
the coca-cola company they are gonna
come out with milk that's right they're
coming out with something called fair
life and we've got some more info for
you farrah life will be more nutritious
with fifty percent more
troll protein high calcium low sugar
form and so the twice the price of a
normal pint according to Coca Cola's
North American chief the milk tastes
better than regular milk and is made on
92 family-owned sustainable dairy farms
with high care processes and proprietary
milk filtering process alright so this
basically sounds good right okay the big
guys coming in may be helping some of
these family-owned farms sustainable a
lot of good buzz words in there call me
a skeptic I have a sense that somehow
this is going to be evil when coat gets
involved in milk what do you think do
you think they're going to make the
wholesome image unwholesome I think it's
quite possible much like when in the
Simpsons the Mafia got involved in
selling milk to the schools and what did
they do mom and it was rat milk so I you
know most of what I know I would rain
all at exactly i think rat milk milk out
like that that's not the the point
that's not the point here yet I'm just
feeling really like a horrible sheep
because like as soon as they said it was
more expensive I was like I want that
that's early it's working on me and I'm
I'm the problem and it's not even out
yet no but really can we trust these big
companies part of me says we can't trust
big companies to get involved in any of
this stuff and then there's another part
of me that you know I watched food inc a
couple months ago and they talked about
how stonyfield farms was this tiny
little family owned whatever and then i
think it was walmart got involved with
them and then they took the same
practices that they had and they just
made it at a bigger scale so as part of
this like you fear the big companies but
sometimes maybe not so bad it's hard for
me to get past the fact this is milk and
i hate milk so you just don't like milk
this is a dairy issue for you what do
you think in terms of in terms of a big
company best case scenario sure the big
companies take over i love them keep
their their sustainable practices but I
feel like that's probably not the norm I
think that story was about Walmart was
probably told because it was like
outside of what normally happens right
because we know that anomaly and it's
exciting that way right much like how
walmart has that commercial where they
have this like pop-up fruit stand and
they show you how fresh all their fruit
is but meanwhile they don't tell you
about the 10 or 20 you know growers that
they probably put out a business that
are right down down the block but do we
need is that what we need to get healthy
food going a little bit more
like to me like going to trader joe's
where I get some organic stuff like
Trader Joe's not a huge company but they
like made it sort of accessible to
someone like me so we do need that kind
of right sure well it's also a different
take on what is healthy and this is like
we're it's more nutritious but why is it
more nutritious are you adding things is
it it's is it because then we have the
organic root and that's like totally
different which is we're not adding all
these things yeah alright well just to
show you a little bit about how big
business gets in on some of this stuff
there of course is a ad campaign all
right there you go I mean she's wearing
milk you see what they're doing their
dream with squirting milk yeah that's a
call barring it back to the porn thing
that's a call back to an earlier segment
will annotate to it right there so you
know we're talking about um yeah so sexy
you don't really think of sexy women
with milk but disgusting you feel like
you actually do exactly already kind of
a stuff but we already have that because
of the mustache right stash thing so you
you associate sexiness with milk i I
don't personally associate sexing with
milk but i'm not i don't think that
they're the first to make that
Association yeah i think that milk is a
long been sexy milk is a sexy beverage I
think of lemonade maybe as a or pink
lemonade does it come from from breasts
the way that milk does yeah but lemonade
that's sexier to me all right citrus is
sex whatever makes whatever makes you
sick tricity sexy how much of this stuff
are you on board in general just sort of
the healthier route let's say that let's
say forget the conspiracy theories about
coke and whatever they're going to let's
say this thing is good and it does
provide what they claim it's going to
provide how much for you guys are you on
board you know great i'm doing the
grass-fed butter thing are you on are
you on any of that kind of stuff I
Louis's smirk already implied that he's
not on the grass well no I mean I'm on
whatever is affordable and it this milk
costs twice as much i'm not going to buy
the milk the cost twice as much right
and i know that's probably where most
people fall right and i think that if
the grass-fed butter costs twice as much
that's not gonna happen either thirty
percent okay responsible farming sure
but if it's like we're injecting these
this new coke brand vitamin into the
things yeah what they don't tell you is
that they're injecting the cows
obviously with coca-cola isn't no
girlhood it is not carbonated but want
God we're gonna carbonated milk it's all
just terrible on that note I
thank Kim and Luis their twitters are
right down below don't forget to comment
on all this stuff subscribe what else do
people do on the youtube they go to
youtube.com slash nerd alert you go to
youtube.com slash nerd alert lewis and
stuff is all down there too and comment
again and all that good stuff on ok we
will see you next week thanks